- [Man On Phone] Tell me that you're
gonna spank me in Irish.
- Oh, I'm gonna spank you so hard.
- [Man On Phone] How
hard you gonna spank me?
- I'm gonna spank you as hard as I can.
(classical music)
- [Narrator] From a worryingly young age,
I've always been curious about the world
of professional phone sex.
So today I roped in two of my coworkers
to join me on my quest
for sexual enlightenment.
Have you ever fondled yourself
while on the phone with someone?
- (laughing) Wow!
- Have I ever had phone se before?
Yes, of course. (laughing)
- No, I've never fondled
myself while on the phone.
- [Narrator] To guide us
on this erotic expedition,
I brought in phone sex
veteran, Mina De Sade,
- I'm Mina De Sade, my vanilla job,
is managing small hospitals,
and a few private medical facilities.
As my personal side job, I
am a phone fantasy artist.
And I say phone fantasy artist.
- I love that.
- Is because you are building a story,
and you're being a story teller.
Based on your listings,
you could be anything
from being a woman of color, that's black,
a gentlemen, barely legal, 18, 19ish.
Hi, I'm Kimberly.
Currently I'm packing things up,
and I had to break up with my boyfriend,
because he's going to
school out in east coast,
and I feel so lonely right
now in my new dorm space.
And I can actually sound
like a real cold bitch,
that will make you go on the floor
and make you suck my shoes for fun.
It's all about.
- (laughing) yes!
- The caller.
Men voices, take off
the tin on your voice,
deepen down, and come from the stomach.
It's all about making them your fan.
The more they're your fan,
the more they will call,
the more longer they
will keep on the lines,
the longer they're on the lines,
the more money you get.
And it works out for everyone.
- (laughing) I love it.
So when they're like, I'm gonna cum,
you're like, not yet daddy, not yet.
- Exactly.
- [Narrator] We have one
of Mina's top clients
on the phone ready for you right now.
- Okay. (laughing)
- Are you serious? (laughing)
No, no.
- [Narrator] We're gonna
throw you in off the deep end.
- This is a real person. (laughing)
- [Narrator] Actually,
he was an actor I hired,
but they didn't need to know that.
All you gotta do is call in,
read from the script, make
sure you're pushing them
to their sexual limit,
alright, you understand?
- I understand.
- [Narrator] Alright, if
you're not getting an erection
out here, you're not
doing it right, alright?
- [Man On Phone] Hello?
- Hello caller, how are you doing today?
I'm just playing with myself right now.
- Oh?
- [Man On Phone] Thinking about you.
What do you want me to do to you?
- What do you like to do to me?
- [Man On Phone] I'm gonna
do so many bad things to you.
You know what I want?
- I want whatever you want.
- Tell me about, what
are the things you like?
- [Man On Phone] I'm
really into Irish men.
- Irish men?
- [Man On Phone] Can you
do an Irish accent for me?
Can you take me to the jungle?
I wanna be naked with you in the jungle.
- What are we doing in the jungle?
I love the jungle.
- [Man On The Phone] Talk to me in Irish.
- I can tell you there's a pot of gold
at the end of the rainbow.
- Describe the environment to them.
- Do you like all the green
of the trees all around us?
- [Man On Phone] Yeah,
I love all the green.
- Top of the mornin' to ya.
I'm gonna get you all undressed
into your clovers, and then we're gonna
spank you into some sexy time.
- It's just me and you
in this jungle, baby.
- [Man On Phone] Yeah?
- Talk about dressing him up.
- I'm gonna put you in a little top hat.
I'm gonna put you in little boots as well.
Do you like that?
- Do you like the sun
coming through the trees?
- [Man On Phone] Can you
sing me a song in Irish?
- I can try.
♫ Oh little laddie, he's been very naughty
- [Man On Phone] I like all
the big trees, they're so good.
- Oh it feels so good, the
sun feels so good on us.
- I'm going to spank you and spank you.
- [Man On Phone] Can you make
some animal noises for me?
(monkey ooing)
- I would not be doing this particular
form of art for almost 20 years,
if I did not think it was fun,
fulfilling, and entertaining.
(laughing)
I do it because I enjoy my callers.
I do it because I love helping
other people and their kinks.
Best caller ever!
- How are you?
- I love being a phone sex artist,
as some may say.
Being a phone fantasy specialist,
is something I will probably
do for another 20 years.
(upbeat music)
♫ Oh little baddie, he's been very naughty
♫ At the end of the rainbow, golden coins
- [Man On Phone] Keep going.